[Music]
welcome back so in this lecture I'm
going to show you how to compress images
using the FFT to command in MATLAB and
this is one of my favorite lectures
because you get a lot of intuition for
how the Fourier transform works because
we we have such deep intuition about
images when you use the FFT for
compressing images I think this is a
really nice example to kind of see how
everything works okay so we're gonna
walk through this this example I'm
actually gonna walk through three
different image image examples here I'm
going to start with the Afghan girl the
famous National Geographic cover picture
it's easy to read images in that lab
using the I M read command we can can
convert this color image to grayscale
using RGB to gray because I only want to
work with a grayscale matrix for
illustration purposes before I do that
I'm going to plot this image for you in
full color and notice that I have 256
minus a where a is my my matrix my image
I'm doing this 256 minus a because I've
inverted my color scheme for this black
background you would just do image SC of
a okay so let's run this code okay so
this is the famous National Geographic
cover of the Afghan girl it's a pretty
high resolution image if I want I can do
size of a and we see that it's almost
square 1400 by 1400 pixels with three
color channels and if I do the same
thing with B if I just type size of B
it's the same 1400 by 1400 pixels but
now we've collapsed those three color
channels into a grayscale Channel okay
so that was the the original image now
we're going to compute the FFT and this
is super simple using the FFT to command
in MATLAB and so if B was my grayscale
image BT is be transformed or be in the
Fourier domain and I'm going to plot for
you these Fourier coefficients but
they're so tiny so many of them are so
small I'm going to have to compute them
on a log scale so there's a lot of stuff
going on here
FFT shift MATLAB remember MATLAB orders
the Fourier coefficients and a bit of a
funny way
so FFT shift will reorder them so that
the lowest frequency modes are at the
origin and the highest frequency modes
are at the corners so that's what FFT
shift does and then I'm taking the
absolute value because these are complex
numbers and I'm taking the logarithm to
plot them on the log scale and because
some of them might be nearly nearly zero
I'm adding one to offset my logarithmic
scale okay
so that's F this shouldn't be F low this
should just be F let's call this F be
log okay I blog and we're going to plot
that for you and again I'm doing 256
minus because I have an inverted color
scheme okay this is what the Fourier
coefficients look like remember this is
on the log scale so most of these gray
regions should actually be completely
black like almost zero value we plotted
them on a log scale to make everything
pop out a little bit more what you see
here is kind of in the origin this is
where the lowest frequency components
are it's the brightest kind of the
highest magnitude values in the origin
and then they kind of decay and get
smaller and smaller and smaller as you
go to higher and higher and higher
frequencies which is kind of consistent
with our intuition that lower frequency
lower frequency modes have more energy
in images that's that's generally true
okay now it's interesting you can see
kind of these these starburst patterns
or at least I can see it and you
definitely have a very strong kind of
vertical and horizontal axis these kind
of white lines at the x and y axes and I
want you to be thinking in the back of
your head why why you would have those
kind of vertical lines in this Fourier
transform and I'll kind of tell you
later if I remember okay but this is the
basic idea remember this is on a log
plot so most of these values unless
they're ultra ultra bright they're very
small so we're going to only keep the
largest magnitude Fourier coefficients
and
and we're gonna use those for the for
the inverse Fourier transform okay
so the main point here is that we're
just computing the FFT to using this
single line in MATLAB that's that's
really the the story is that it's easy
to compute this Fourier transform
everything else was just plotting and so
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
use this Fourier transform for
compression okay so what we're going to
do is we're going to manually pull out
just the largest 99% of the Fourier
coefficients the largest five percent
coefficients the largest one percent and
the largest point two percent of the
coefficients so we're gonna keep
basically 99% of them five percent of
them one percent and point two percent
of the largest coefficients manually and
then after we zero out everything else
we're going to inverse Fourier transform
and see how good our image looks how
we're going to compress a lot and we're
gonna see how much degradation there is
in our image and the way I do this this
is actually like a homework I get from
my students at the University of
Washington what we're going to do is
we're going to sort our Fourier
coefficients from line 11 so these are
my Fourier transform coefficients we're
basically going to turn that array of
Fourier coefficients into a really
really big vector using this beatty of :
that vector eise's it then we sort them
from biggest to smallest okay so that's
B T sort and then what we're going to do
is we're basically going to pick a
threshold so we're gonna pick like the
top you know 1% the top 5% the top 99%
and we're going to use that threshold to
determine which of those coefficients
are larger in the largest 5% and which
ones are in the you know the 95% that
are going to get truncated okay so
that's how you pick your threshold so
that's that's where you draw the line in
terms of Fourier magnitude this line
here indices equals the magnitude of B T
greater than threshold what that does is
it creates an array the same size as my
original Fourier transform matrix of
zeros and ones it will be 0 everywhere
where the Fourier magnitude is smaller
than threshold and it'll be 1 everywhere
that its larger than threshold and so in
that way this indicee matrix is
basically a mask if I take my Fourier
transform matrix and I multiply it with
this indices matrix it will zero out all
of the small coefficients that are below
threshold and it'll keep all the big
coefficients that are above threshold
okay and then all I'm gonna do is
basically inverse fast Fourier transform
and then show you the image okay so
let's do that right now okay excellent
and so here we have I've shown kind of
99 if you keep 99% of these Fourier
coefficients so basically no compression
at all you can think of this is the full
high-resolution image and then we have
our 5% where we only kept 5% of the
coefficients we only kept 1% of the
coefficients and we only kept point 2%
of the coefficients so this is a
compression ratio of 20 we compress by a
factor of 20 here we compressed by a
factor of 100 and here we compressed by
a factor of 500 so massive compression
we're only keeping a very small amount
of the Fourier coefficients and I want
to walk you through kind of how these
different compressions look so right off
the bat you actually see that the 5% and
the 1% image compression look really
really good you can see most of the
features in this image are retained
there's relatively little kind of lack
of a degradation of image quality here
in the 500 times compression you can see
that now the image looks really grainy
this looks like it kind of an old
photograph that's really grainy and
there's a lot of features missing here
so so 0.2% was over compression we were
too aggressive we zeroed out too many
important Fourier coefficients but the
one percent and the five percent are
actually looking pretty good now I'm
gonna zoom into the eyes just so you can
see that there is actually some image
degradation happening even in the the
one percent case so I'm going to try to
just zoom into all of the eyes here and
what you're going to see is that
in the full resolution image and in the
5% compression they're actually pretty
close okay so there are some details in
the full image in the kind of IRAs and
glint that aren't perfectly captured in
the 5% or in the 20 times compression
but I'd say this is pretty good when you
get to the hundred times compression
ratio now you can see now that we're
zoomed in there's still a lot of details
that are missing here so you can't
release the eyelashes you can't really
see resolution of the of the cornea and
iris and by the time you get over here
it's almost completely obliterated that
fine fine structure okay so that's okay
so that's our first example just to show
you first of all that when you Fourier
transform most of the coefficients are
small and you can get away with throwing
away you know at least 95% of those
coefficients without serious degradation
to the image quality okay good
back to my original question why are
there let me go back up here why are
there so many why are is the Fourier
transform so bright in the vertical and
horizontal axes here corresponding to
kind of zero frequency in Y and zero
frequency in X and the answer hopefully
some of you were were following this the
answer is that remember the Fourier
transform only works for perfectly
periodic signals okay so it has to be
periodic and X and periodic and why
because we're decomposing this in sines
and cosines this image is not perfectly
periodic and in fact it's more periodic
and X because the green boundaries are
closer to being the same in X but it's
it's actually not very periodic in Y
notice the entire top boundary is green
and most of the bottom boundary is red
okay so this is not actually periodic
there's a jump discontinuity in the
pixel values at the top and the bottom
and the left and the right and so that
manifests itself as this big vertical
bright lines in the horizontal direction
so you'll see that when you Fourier
transform images generally speaking are
those kind of lines okay good
let's try another example I'm gonna do
this dog cat example here so that's an
adorable picture of a dog and a cat kind
of nuzzling and we're gonna see how this
is a smaller image you can already tell
that this is a much smaller image in
fact let's just see how size of a it's
only 437 by 660 pixels so I'm gonna
Fourier transform similarly we get this
for you transform and now we're gonna do
the same compression okay good so what
do you notice
in this image so again 99% to 5% there's
relatively little degradation like 5% is
definitely better than 1% or 0.2% but
what I would point out here is that in
all of these compressions the compressed
image looks worse than it did for the
Afghan girl okay so all of these
compressions at 5% at 1% at 0.2 percent
are worse than the compression for the
higher resolution Afghan girl image and
and one of the reasons is the bigger the
image is to begin with the higher the
resolution your starting image generally
speaking the more you can compress it
the smaller the image the more you need
those Fourier coefficients to represent
the things in that image so high
resolution images are more compressible
than low res images but the other thing
I think is really interesting here this
entire image has a lot of texture it's
got a lot of grass and fur and grass and
fur are notoriously difficult to
compress using the Fourier transform
because they're very high frequency if
you think about this grass that's very
very high frequency in space and the fur
is even higher frequency in space so
hair is really hard to compress and to
model in the Fourier domain so you also
get less compression just because the
thing you're trying to compress has more
high frequency content there's more
stuff out here that matters okay and
actually this was a big deal for Pixar
so if you look at the history of Pixar
movies there
first movie Toy Story no one had hair
they were all plastic dolls because it
was much much easier to render plastic
smooth plastic surfaces than hair and
texture and fur
okay so there's actually this
progression of Pixar movies when they
went from being able to model smooth
plastic to furry monsters and that was a
big deal because this is a lot harder to
compress and to represent okay good
in the last example I'll show just my
dog Mordecai which is a very
high-resolution image so I'm going to do
the whole thing again so that's more
that's this FFT and this is the
compression and again because this is a
very high-resolution image you can get
away with compressing more even though
there is some texture and some fur and
you know he has modeled a model backside
but you can still compress more pretty
effectively because it's just a very
high-resolution image okay good okay
excellent so that's kind of what I
wanted to show you about about image
compression how you use the fast Fourier
transform to compress these images in
some future lecture I would like to show
you that you can actually plot these
images as surfaces so I think that would
be kind of a cool thing to show you in
fact let me just see if I can if I can
do this right now a low tend to tend to
end 10 - 10 - and that's always a little
dangerous to do this live coding okay so
this is that low pass that this is the
FFT
compressed version of the Afghan girl
and I've only picked every tenth pixel
because it would be far too high
dimensional to plot the surface and this
is this is every pixel intensity plotted
as a height so higher intensity pixels
are higher on this surface plot I
actually made this visualization because
I was showing this to my mom and I was
trying to
Wayne kind of how the Fourier transform
worked for image compression and I
realized that this would be the best way
to show her is to plot everything as a
pixel intensity and what you see here
that is the Afghan girl okay and this is
her face kind of the intense pixels the
so the the whites of her eye are maybe
the brightest pixels those are the peaks
of the mountain and everything that's
bright is higher than everything that's
dark so the qaol kind of her shadow and
the cowl is is lower valleys and the
brights of her eyes are higher and this
is the little colors are inverted here
so it's a little bit backwards but this
gives you an idea of what we're doing in
image compression so what we're trying
to do is approximate this surface this
is literally a surface of pixel
intensities by a sum of spatial wave
numbers so those those four people
standing on equal sides of this bedsheet
you hold it tight and then the first two
people pump in the X direction at some
spatial frequency the other two people
in the Y Direction pump at a different
frequency and you create this kind of
sinusoidal bedsheet and if you add
enough of those up you can make this
kind of mountainous landscape here
that's what we're doing each of these
Fourier coefficients is kind of like
that bed sheet at a different frequency
and you're going to add those up in a
perfect proportion to reconstruct the
pixel intensity of this face okay so I
just love this visualization it's super
cool you can see kind of the the
intensity and what we're trying to
approximate with this Fourier transform
okay okay good so this is how you
compress images with the Fourier
transform in later lectures I'll show
you how to do this using an even better
compression using the wavelet transform
so it's built on the FFT but it's a
better basis to compress images in okay
thank you